let's talk to some more people it's
Friday after all we take calls via
Discord davidpackman.com
slash Discord why don't we go next later
we'll see where we go but let's go next
to Joseph from Tucson Arizona uh the
place in Arizona where I've spent the
most time by far Joseph welcome to the
program what's going on
hey thank you David uh can you hear me
yes I can
so just hypothetically speaking yes if
Trump were to get indicted sometime this
year okay and Trump supporters were to
violently
um riot in response yes would that hurt
Republicans in 2024
interesting question
um I think the answer depends on who's
the nominee right if Trump is indicted
and his supporters Riot and Trump
doesn't denounce it and he is the
nominee I think that that hurts Trump if
Trump gets indicted and his supporters
Riot and Trump either drops out or loses
the nomination
I think that whoever is the eventual
nominee probably isn't affected
negatively by these hypothetical Trump
riots you're talking about so I think it
depends on who is the nominee
interesting yeah I was kind of thinking
long similar lines um where it
definitely would hurt Trump um kind of
um in either way kind of damned if he
dust in if he doesn't kind of thing
um and deservedly so I'd probably say
what do you mean by that damned if he
does you're saying whether or not he
denounces or what do you mean
I think either way he definitely would
face a lot of backlash
um obviously from the left but I think
in a lot of pockets of the right
um if a combination of a trump
indictment and violent riots were to
occur I think a lot of the smaller
pockets of the right who are more quiet
about their disdain for Trump would be a
lot louder and I think uh would gain a
lot more support
um because of such
um uh a violent occurrence that very
well may be that very well may be let's
hope there is no such violence uh that
would be the best thing
yeah um that would obviously be the best
um the best course of action um and as a
kind of unrelated uh side question sure
um I was wondering if you had any uh
book recommendations related to U.S
foreign policy
uh I really don't I tend not to read uh
sort of like new foreign policy type
books I have so many other things on my
on my pile including science and
narrative non-fiction and history and
different things I I just don't I I'm
not really reading in that genre right
now so I don't have any recommendations
okay that's fine all right thank you for
taking my call all right Joseph from
Tucson great to hear from you